nouveau numéro de reporters sur France
24 direction les Caraïbes trinidades et
Tobago est un archipel situé entre le
Venezuela et les Antilles c'est un
million et demi d'habitants forment une
communauté
héritière d'une longue histoire
coloniale le pays détient pourtant un
triste record entre 2013 et 2016 plus de
130 habitants de Trinidad seraient parti
rejoindre les rangs de daesh rapporté à
sa population c'est l'un des plus grands
contingents de candidats au djihad au
monde avec nous Cyril charpentier
bonjour Cyril bonjour Antoine vous avez
enquêté comment expliquer ce foyer
d'Islam radical en plein cœur des
Caraïbes écoutez l'islam à Trinidad
s'explique par la colonisation les
premiers musulmans à débarqué à Trinidad
ce sont les immigrés indiens arrivés
pour remplacer les esclaves dans les
plantations et puis il y a une deuxième
vague d'islamisation à Trinidad qui se
place dans les années 60 et 70 avec
l'émergence de la Nation of Islam
retrouver ce groupe américain qui
professe un retour à la religion
originelle des Afro-Américains l'islam
et un de ces principaux tenants
principaux leaders de ce mouvement là
Yassine aboubacre s'est rendu célèbre à
Trinidad pour avoir organisé un coup
d'État en 1990 qui a échoué mais qui a
permis à d'autres de ses disciples de
former des groupuscules un peu
sécessionnistes si vous voulez et ce
sont ceux-là qui sont radicalisés et qui
ont pu financer les départs en Syrie des
candidats au djihad alors on va
découvrir ce reportage vous retrouve
juste après reportage que vous avez
tourné avec Damien LANSAD à Trinidad et
Tobago
[Musique]
depuis 4 ans la vie de Rahima Kahn et
suspendue au rare nouvelle de sa sœur
la sœur de Rahima Kahn et ses cinq
enfants sont aujourd'hui détenus dans le
camp de roche en Syrie toutes les
semaines ma soeur nous envoie une note
vocale elle utilise le téléphone du camp
comme ma nièce elle est impatiente
[Musique]
en 2014 sa sœur qui Trinidad pour la
Syrie comme elle plus de 130
Trinidadiens se répartir rejoindre les
rangs de daesh entre 2013 et 2016
en 2019 elle se retrouve sous les bombes
pendant le siège de bagouse le dernier
bastion de l'État islamique elle arrive
à fuir la ville mais très vite elle est
arrêtée par les forces de la coalition
c'était il y a 4 ans
cela fait si longtemps qu'elle est
là-bas elle a développé des troubles
mentaux je pense qu'elle souffre de
stress post-traumatique
son esprit par ailleurs elle ne sait
même plus qui elle est elle perd la
mémoire
elle ne reconnaît même plus ses enfants
inquiète pour la santé de sa sœur Rahim
à Cannes décide de tout mettre en oeuvre
pour la faire rentrer à Trinidad sa mère
qui tient à garder son anonymat a
toujours l'espoir de revoir enfin sa
fille et ses petits-enfants
elle a acheté ce jouet pour le plus
petit
des serre-tête pour sa petite fille elle
n'arrête pas d'en acheter elle met
toutes ces choses de côté pour ma sœur
et ses enfants
je n'arrête pas de lui dire qu'elle doit
arrêter
parce qu'il ne se passe rien
comme la sœur et les neveux d'oreille
Macan de nombreuses femmes et enfants
ont été fait prisonniers
90 Trinidadiens seraient aujourd'hui
enfermés dans des camps en Syrie parmi
eux 56 mineurs dont 33 serait né sur
place
le gouvernement retarde leur retour
officiellement pour des raisons de
sécurité intérieure
avec 5% de la population l'Islam et la
troisième religion de Trinidad
fois est un des cadres de la Jama Talmud
cette organisation promeut un rôle
social et politique de la religion
elle a été fondée par son père Yassine
aboubach connu pour avoir organisé un
coup d'État en 1990
dans les années 70 la Djama
talmousloumine a été au cœur des luttes
anti coloniales des communautés afro
caribéenne
c'était une époque d'éveil et de prise
de conscience dans les Caraïbes
le mouvement Black Power incité les
Africains à retrouver leurs racines
ainsi que leur religion d'origine
oui
[Musique]
nous ne disons pas se convertir mais
bien revenir vers l'Islam
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est cette même idéologie qui
a pu pousser certains de ses
compatriotes à adhérer à la propagande
de l'État islamique
ils sont partis pour trouver mieux ils
sont partis à la poursuite du utopie la
création d'un État islamique
il voulait faire partie de quelque chose
de bien quelque chose de positif quelque
chose d'islamique
comme Foda Booba plusieurs leaders
religieux minimistes aujourd'hui la
vocation guerrière de ses candidats au
djihad
[Musique]
il a participé au coup d'État organisé
par Yassine aboubac et reconnaît par
ailleurs avoir eu des liens avec
Al-Qaïda
les informations auxquelles nous avions
accès à l'époque n'était pas le genre
d'information qui aurait pu empêcher les
départs
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais découragé ceux qui
voulaient partir
pourtant dès sa création l'État
islamique mettait en scène ses exactions
cette femme a subi la terreur de daesh
pour garder son anonymat elle se fait
appeler Solange
il y avait beaucoup de bombardements et
de mort
la police de daesh était très stricte et
leur sanction était toujours très sévère
donc il fallait juste obéir
toujours obéir
sinon on finissait en prison
où on pouvait être exécuté
après avoir réussi à fuir elle est
rentrée à Trinidad avec ses deux enfants
avec l'aide de son avocat elle a engagé
des démarches judiciaires pour que son
fils né en Syrie obtienne la nationalité
trinidadienne
le 13 on devrait recevoir le certificat
de citoyenneté de votre fils le 13
Solange dit avoir été piégé par son mari
il lui aurait fait croire qu'il avait
décroché un contrat de footballeur en
Turquie
mais elle se retrouve finalement en
Syrie soumise à la loi de l'État
islamique
m'a demandé à mon mari de pouvoir
rentrer à la maison
il m'a traîné au tribunal car si on ne
peut pas rester cela veut dire qu'on est
en espion et un des types m'a dit que je
pourrais avoir ma tête coupée qu'il
pourrait me tuer pour ça
alors j'ai commencé à obéir à leurs
règles
et j'ai échafaudé un plan pour m'évader
Solange réussi finalement à s'échapper
et à gagner une zone contrôlée par les
forces turques
réfugiés dans un camp elle parvient à
contacter son consulat le récit et
l'épreuve de son évasion lui permet
d'être reconnu comme victime de daesh
elle est rapatriée en 2016 mais son
retour à la vie normale se révèle vite
difficile
je ne porte plus mon voile
car j'étais discriminée à mon retour
je pense que c'est injuste
car tout le monde fait des erreurs et
parfois ce n'est même pas de leur faute
la plupart des femmes que j'ai rencontré
là-bas
c'était la faute de leur mari elle ne
savait même pas où elles allaient
comment tu vas ça va ça va le sort de
ces femmes n'affiza Mohamed on a fait
son combat
cet ancienne députée aider Brahim à
Cannes dans ses démarches pour faire
rentrer sa sœur ensemble elles alertent
sur les conditions de vie difficiles des
femmes et enfants détenus en Syrie
il a tout juste trois ans il est né dans
le camp tout ce que cet enfant connaît
c'est la vie sous une tente
le gouvernement de Trinidad est au Bago
travaille depuis 2018 sur une nouvelle
loi anti-terroriste afin de rapatrier
ces ressortissants tout en garantissant
la sécurité du pays
5 ans après ce projet de loi n'a
toujours pas vu le jour
si l'on pèse le pour et le contre oui il
y a des enjeux de sécurité intérieure
que l'on doit prendre en compte mais si
l'on considère les enjeux humanitaires
c'est vers ceci qu'il faut faire pencher
la balance et non vers des contes
sidération sécuritaires pour toutes ces
personnes les conditions de vie dans les
camps sont atroces avec des égouts à
ciel ouvert aucun logement décent ils
doivent dormir à même le sol malgré les
rats les maladies sont légion l'eau est
contaminée
de nombreux trinides Indiens prisonniers
des concitriens ne peuvent pas obtenir
de documents d'identité sans passeport
ils ne peuvent pas rentrer chez eux
mais affisamment Ahmed conseil alors les
familles dans leur démarche judiciaire
actuellement trois procès contre l'état
de Trinidad et Tobago sont toujours en
cours
il y aurait des responsables qui
oseraient fermer les yeux sur la
détresse de ces gens je dis non c'est
inacceptable la communauté musulmane
contribue depuis des années à développer
ce pays nous sommes capables de vivre en
paix et de travailler tous ensemble main
dans la main ce sont des femmes et des
enfants qui sont dans une position
vulnérable et ils ont besoin d'être
protégés
en 2019 le retour des enfants de felicha
Perkins a été un événement médiatique
séparer de ces deux fils après leur
enlèvement par leur père parti faire le
jihad elle avait perdu tout espoir de
les revoir mais après une opération
humanitaire financée par le leader Pink
Floyd Philippe chat Perkins a pu les
ramener à Trinidad
tout ce qu'il voulait c'est être près de
moi retrouvez leur maman j'ai dû
rattraper le temps perdu avec eux
jusqu'à ce qu'il commence à reprendre
pied avec la réalité
souhaite que ses enfants soient les
exemples d'une réintégration réussie
ils ont vu tellement de choses beaucoup
de cadavres décorent déchiquetés c'est
vraiment trop baptisant pour des enfants
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est vivre
normalement être comme les autres ne pas
être pointé du doigt au ridiculisé pour
quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas choisi
alors arriver le gouvernement a lancé
une commission pour gérer les retours de
séries pendant un an les enfants de
Philippe chat Perkins ont bénéficié d'un
accompagnement psychologique
mais aujourd'hui ces enfants ne sont
plus suivis et les travaux de la
commission sont à l'arrêt aucun traîné
d'indien n'a été rapatriés depuis quatre
ans
je pense que le gouvernement pourrait
vraiment faire plus pour les faire
rentrer et les aider à retrouver leur
vie d'avant parce que tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est grandir normalement
malgré nos demandes répétées le
gouvernement de trinda de Tobago n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
selon humin rice watch plus de 40 000
étrangers seraient toujours retenu dans
des camps en Syrie près de la moitié
aurait moins de 12 ans
et on retrouve en plateau Cyril
charpentier Cyril quels étaient les
motivations de ceux qui sont partis
faire le jihad écoutez les motivations
sont aussi multiples que les profils des
candidats au djihad nous avons des fils
de bonne famille qui sont partis pour
pouvoir financer l'État islamique nous
avons des enfants du ghetto comme
Solange que vous avez vu en reportage
mais la particularité de trididate c'est
avant tout que les combattants sont
partis avec leur famille avec femmes et
enfants et ça a pu un peu leur ligne de
défense si vous voulez puisque ils
disent nous on n'est pas partie faire la
guerre puisqu'on est parti en famille et
on va pas faire la guerre avec des
femmes et des enfants donc c'est une île
de défense un peu rhétorique sûrement
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ils ont
sûrement voulu fuir un peu la société de
Trinidad qui n'allait pas dans leur sens
qui n'était pas assez musulmane pour eux
alors quel avenir pour ceux qui sont
détenus retenus dans les camps alors
l'avenir est très incertain puisque le
gouvernement de Trinidad bloque
complètement tous les retours alors il
est vrai que le pays est en je connais
plusieurs crises si vous voulez vous
avez une économique puis c'est un pays
pétrolier les réserves diminuent les
revenus avec vous avez une crise
migratoire très importante avec le
Venezuela qui se trouve à quelques
kilomètres de Trinidad et une crise
sécuritaire extrêmement grave puisque la
corruption et le trafic du cocaïne
gangrène toute la société donc le
gouvernement a d'autres priorités si
vous voulez que 130 personnes
et que c'est en panne priorité il y a un
deuxième point aussi très important
c'est que le gouvernement a peur d'un
retour de bâton de l'opinion qui est
plutôt défavorable au retour de ce genre
là ceci dit il y a un petit espoir
puisque les avocats des familles
concernées
travaillent judiciairement pour pouvoir
appliquer la loi Trinidad puisque la loi
normalement garantit l'accès au pays à
tous ses citoyens il n'y a pas de loin
et terroristes qui permettrait de
bloquer leur retour donc voilà donc il y
a un travail judiciaire qui est en cours
un travail administratif pour qu'ils
aient des passeports et une de mes
sources espérer que d'ici la fin de
l'année ou l'année prochaine il y aura
des premiers des premiers retours
Cyril charpentier donc de retour de
Trinidad et Tobago pour se reportage
merci Cyril c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]